[музика]
Дорогі українці напередодні різдвяних та
новорічних свят Ми всі загадуємо бажання
цьогоріч воно в нас одне на всіх
Ми прагнемо Перемоги і мріємо або всі
наші Захисники повернулися додому
[музика]
А наближаємо ми цю мить кожен на своєму
фронті
один з таких фронтів тримає і наша
освітянська спільнота
Шановні колеги за 31 рік незалежності
нашої держави саме ви виховали та
навчили покоління патріотичних
волелюбних та сміливих українців а
сьогодні ви продовжуєте вчити наших
дітей
поприбут які виклики
вас не зупиняють повітряна тривоги
аварійні відключення світла маленькі
відсоток зарядки гаджету і тисячі
кілометрів відстані до окремих з ваших
учнів
ба більше
вас не залякала окупація
не зламали погрози та шантаж від
підступного і жорстокого ворога
я пишаюсь з кожним українським
вихователем вчителям викладачем
науковцям та новатором
також мене бере Гордість і за кожного з
наших здобувачів освіти
бо навіть під час війни ви продовжуєте
обирати рідну Україну для навчання
отримання кваліфікації та нових професій
цей рік був складним і жорстоким але
водночас
2022 став дуже показовим
ми мали можливість збагнути наскільки
насправді українці щирі у своїй Любові
до батьківщини а також ми побачили як
здатні буквально творити дива коли
об'єднані та згуртовані однією важливою
метою
Я хочу або кожен з вас на хвилинку
заплющу очі та спробував уявити А дехто
просто згадати як українська освітня
спільнота прожила цей рік на десятий
день війни освітяни Хто б Де не був
повернулися до процесу навчання своїх
учнів
хто з підвалу приватного будинку Хто з
подвір'я чужої хати на Тернопільщині А
хто навіть із напівзруйнованою
багатоповерхівки
але Всі вийшли на зв'язок до своїх
п'ятикласників чи першокурсників усі ви
знайшли можливість
провести урок чи прочитати лекцію
і всі ви замість валізи з теплими речами
відправляючись у тимчасову евакуацію з
рідного міста брали з собою підручник
влітку якби не було складно успішно
стартували і пройшла повноцінна вступна
кампанія
Вона проходила одночасно в Україні та ще
у 32 країнах світу і було адаптована
таким чином щоб кожна дитина змогла
реалізувати своє право на здобуття
освіти в Україні
спочатку пункти тестування а згодом і
приймальні комісії закладів вищої освіти
працювали не знаючи Ані втоми Ані страху
перед загрозами ракетних обстрілів
У підсумку понад 600 тисяч абітурієнтів
вступили до омріяних університетів
коледжів і профтехів в рідній Україні
паралельно в літні напружені місяці
вчителі та директори шкіл готувалися до
початку нового навчального року в
традиційному форматі
[музика]
це здавалося неможливим але прагнення
зберегти право українських дітей на
доступ до якісної освіти стало
пріоритетним і 1 вересня 1000 маленьких
українців так і зустріли свято знань за
партами в своїх рідних школах
і не змогла зупинити освітній процес в
Україні Він тривав і буде продовжуватися
Бо як я вже казав нашу перемогу над
ворогом Ми наближаємо кожен на своєму
фронті
буду відверто українськими освітянами та
дітьми захоплюються Сьогодні весь світ
А ви всі
невпинно створюєте для цього все нові і
нові привиди Наші учні та студенти
наприклад гідно представили Україну на
таких міжнародних змаганнях як
всесвітньо-літня гімназіада
Європейський університетські ігри Кубок
світу з єдиноборств чемпіонат світу з
футзалу ми вибороли 177 медалей з яких
49 золотих
дорогі Мої колеги освітяни і науковці
попри біль принесений війною гори та
районування ви стали міццю яка своїм
прикладом надихає наших дітей діяти
вчитися ставати кращими мудрішими та
освіченішими і це явище Я вважаю
безцінним багатством нашої держави
з кожним днем перемоги України все
ближче ви це добре знаєте А я знаю що ми
обов'язково її зустрінемо на відміну
Прийміть найщиріші вітання з прийдешніми
святами
нехай небо над вами буде мирним а ваші
серця Нехай будуть сповнені Віри Надії
та любові З новим роком вас з Різдвом
Христовим тримаємось ми сильні ми
Україна З повагою до вас